ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
[inaudible]
DALY EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LEVINE LOW MOAN [inaudible]
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES IS
[inaudible]
REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
STEINORTH STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
SEEING BOTH [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OURGUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
AS WE RETURN TO THE HEAT THE
TYPICAL SACRAMENTO AUGUST.
I RECALL THE WINTER VACATION MY
WIFE PATTY AND I ENJOYED.
AT THE SUBTOTAL SNOW FESTIVAL IN
HOKKAIDO JAPAN.
WE SAW MASSIVE BLOCKS OF ICE
TRANSFORMED INTO ARTISTIC
CREATION.
IT WAS AMAZING.
AND GETTING UP CLOSE AND
TOUCHING THE SCULPTURES ALLOWED
US TO APPRECIATE THE DETAIL OF
THE WORK EVEN MORE.
BUT IT'S PATTY SAID TO ME.
WHAT PLACE FEES FESTIVAL THIS
FESTIVAL ON HER BUCKET LIST WITH
NOT JUST THE ARTISTIC BEAUTY OF
THE INTRICATE ICE CARVINGS?
THE BEAUTY THAT SHE APPRECIATED
APART THE CARVINGS WAS TO BE
FOUND IN THEIR DELICATE
IMPERMANENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS BUT METIS TRULY
APPRECIATE THE INCREDIBLE ICE
SCULPTURES.
WITH THE REALITY THAT THEY WOULD
LAST FOR ONLY THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS.
THESE ICE CREATIONS COULD ONLY
BE ENJOYED FOR LITTLE WHILE.
IF THE WERE CARVED IN GRANTED
AYE STONE.
PEOPLE WOULD NOT FLOCK TO
SUPPORT OR IN THE FREEZING COLD
OF WINTER TO ADMIRE THEM.
IF THEY WERE MADE OF PLASTIC OR
STEEL.
PEOPLE COULD GO IN THE
COMFORTABLE SPRING OR SUMMER TO
SEE THEM.
BUT THEIR BEAUTY WOULD LOSE
SIGNIFICANT.
IS BECAUSE THEY WERE CREATED
FROM ICE AND SNOW.
THAT WE BRAVED THE FREEZING
WEATHER WITH THOUSANDS OF OTHER
PEOPLE. TO EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
CAN MUST CITY.
THE SNOW FESTIVAL.
AS PATTY SAID.
IT WAS THE DELEGATE IMPERMANENCE
OF THE ICE SCULPTURES.
THE REQUIRED US TO ADMIRE AND
APPRECIATE THEM NOW.
IN LIFE NOTHING CAN LAST FOREVER.
WHEN WE VIEW OUR LIVES WITH SUCH
DEEP REFLECTION?
OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN TO SEE
AGAIN.
WHAT IS TRULY OF VALUE IN LIFE?
OUR LIVES TO OR AS BEAUTIFUL AND
IS DELICATE AS THE ICE
SCULPTURES BUT WINTER FESTIVAL.
AT THE VERY MOST.
THE LIFE OF AN ICE SCULPTURE CAN
BE ONLY ONE WINTER LONG.
WITH WISDOM EYES CHU THE OPEN.
WE WILL CHERISH EACH AND EVERY
MOMENT.
WE ABLE TO BE TOGETHER.
WITH GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
WITH KINDNESS INGRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS NOW MORE.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MACE.
READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
[inaudible]
PAPER [inaudible]
DIAZ.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JULY FIFTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE SAME AT TWELVE NOON
ON FULLER FRIEDMAN ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM ASSEMBLY
RELATING TO PUT THE DOTS OF
WILSON AT THE DESPOTS PLAGUED
IMMEASURABLE CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON A COMEY ARROW.
AND FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BILL BRO.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL GIMMICKS SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
MEDINA IN THIS AREA AND QUIRK TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA
CUNNINGHAM LACKEY AND PATTERSON
TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT AND
MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS I'M
GIVING IT ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE ENACT FILE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN S. B. ONE THIRTY
FOUR HERNANDEZ AND ITEM A
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
NIELSEN.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL
CITY INACTIVE FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE A. B..
THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN BY ANY
GARCIA ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX A. B..
THREE ZERO ZERO NINE BY COR.
THE CLERK WILL NOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX PLEASE WITHDRAW S. B. A
TWENTY TWO WIENER FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND RE
REFER THE BILL TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN THE CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS
IN THE CHAMBER.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISS
GARCIA MISTER CA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU GET A
MORNING MEMBERS.
IT'S WITH GREAT PRIDE THAT I AM
ABLE 2% MISS A PF SAID TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY.
I MISS THERE HAS BEEN A RESIDENT
TO READ US FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS.
IS THE BOARD MEMBER OF ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A
PROFESSOR COMPTON COLLEGES
NURSING DEPARTMENT.
ALL THE EVERY CHILDREN ATTEND
THAT ABC SCHOOLS.
SHE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN HER
CHILDREN'S SCHOOLS PTSA BOARD
MEMBER.
ACKERMAN NEED OUT MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND WHITNEY HIGH SCHOOL.
CHAIRWOMAN WOULD BE HAS QUIT
CHINESE PTSA AND VOLUNTEER NURSE
PRACTITIONER FOR CERRITOS HIGH
SCHOOL SOCCER TEAM.
I OFTEN BRAG ABOUT ABC UNIFIED
I'D BE ONE OF THE BEST DISTRICTS --
IN THIS STATE IN THE NATION
INCLUDING THAT THE HIGH SCHOOL
AND SO IT'LL BE S. AS A BIG PART
OF MAKING SURE WE HAVE THAT
SUCCESS IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DIDN'T MISS SAYS ALSO LIAISON
FOR THE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AT HOCQUART ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
SHE BELIEVES THAT EDUCATIONAL
INSTRUCTION SHOULD DEVELOP ALL
ASPECTS OF THE STUDENTS.
INCLUDING THE PHYSICAL
INTELLECTUAL SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASPECTS IN ORDER
TO CREATE A WELL ROUNDED
INDIVIDUAL.
MOREOVER SHE STRONGLY FEELS THAT
SUCCESS IN THE STUDENT'S
EDUCATION CAN ONLY OCCUR THROUGH
STRONG PARENTAL INVOLVEMENT IN
[inaudible]
PATIENT --
THROUGH OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
HELPS LEAD APPARENT I ADVOCACY
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE EVERY YEAR
INSIDIOUS ALSO HERE CELEBRATING
WITH HER FRIENDS UP FROM HER
NURSING SCHOOL.
A LOT OF THEM ARE RESIDENTS IN
THE AREA --
AND SAYS EXCITING HE'S ABLE TO
COME DOWN HERE THAT WE CAN
RECOGNIZE THAT WE CAN THINK OF
FOR HER SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY
AND FOR ALL OF THE STUDENTS AYE
AND ABC UNIFIED.
PLEASE HELP ME IN WELCOMING SAID
HE IS SAID TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS IN THE
CHAMBER [inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
I BELIEVE YOUR GAS HAVE ARRIVED
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY GIRL SCOUT TROOP. ONE
ZERO NINE SEVEN SEVEN FROM
PETALUMA WELCOME GIRL SCOUTS IN
THE GALLERY WE'VE GOT FOURTEEN
SCOUTS.
THEIR TROOP LEADERS CHEN
FREEZING AND SUSAN HURLEY
THEREFORE CHAPERONES.
AND WE EVEN HAVE A TAG ALONG BOY
SCOUT HANGING OUT WITH US TODAY
AS WELL BIG YOU FOR COMING THEY
ARE HERE FOR A TOUR OF THE
CAPITOL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM AS
PART OF THEIR STUDIES IN CIVIC
ADVOCACY WERE REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE HERE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING.
THE MEMBERS OF GIRL SCOUT TROOP
ONE ZERO NINE SEVEN SEVEN TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
AND MR MEDINA.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUEST.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
WELCOME THE CIVIL AIR PATROL.
THE OFFICIAL AUXILIARY OF THE U.
S. AIR FORCE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THE CIVIL AIR PATROL IS
COMPRISED OF MANY.
UNSUNG HEROES.
AS VOLUNTEERS TO SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY.
WITHOUT PAYING.
THE MEMBERS OPERATE A FLEET OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY AIRCRAFT.
NATIONALLY.
AND CONDUCT 90% OF THE AIRFORCE
DOMESTICS SEARCH AND RESCUE
MISSIONS. THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA WING.
HELP TO PERFORM VITAL NATIONAL
SECURITY AND DISASTER RELIEF
MISSIONS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
CIVIL AIR PATROL ALSO RUNS AN
OUTSTANDING CADET PROGRAM.
IT TEACHES YOUNG PEOPLE THE
IMPORTANCE OF LEADERSHIP.
WHILE EMPHASIZING STEM AND
AEROSPACE EDUCATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY.
JOINING ME TODAY IS COLONEL ALAN
FERGUSON CALIFORNIA WING
COMMANDER.
WITH LIEUTENANT COLONEL MARK
KEMPTEN.
AND LIEUTENANT COLONEL KEVIN
CUMMINGS.
SIMILAR PATROL MEMBERS WHO
CADETS ARE ALSO WATCHING IN THE
GALLERY.
MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME TO
WELCOME SUCH AN HONORABLE GROUP
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER.
MR IS SORRY AND YOU ARE. FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUEST PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GIVE ME
A GREAT HONOR AND PERSONAL JOY
TO RECOGNIZE AN ORGANIZATION
THAT I MYSELF HAVE BEEN A PART
OF AND WHOSE MOTTO ALWAYS STANDS
AS RISE.
AND RAISE WITH YOU --
TODAY A STAND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARMENIAN LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO RECOGNIZE THE ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IS YOUR ATTENTION MR IS AREA.
THE ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ARMENIAN GENERAL ATHLETIC
UNION AND SCOUTS REFERRED TO AS
HOME MINUTEMAN.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AND
SERVING OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND YOU.
IN FIVE CONTINENTS HOW MANY
MEN'S MISSION IS TO PREPARE
EXEMPLARY AND LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS BY PROVIDING PHYSICAL
AND HEALTH EDUCATION.
TEACHING SPORTSMANSHIP AND
HELPING YOUTH CULTIVATE A SENSE
OF RESPONSIBILITY AN HONOR AS
THEY STRIVE FOR INDIVIDUAL AND
COLLECTIVE EXCELLENCE.
AS A FORMER MEMBER MYSELF --
IT IS A PLEASURE TO WELCOME HOME
AND MEN AND ITS MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR TO CELEBRATE. ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OF SERVING NOT
JUST THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY BUT
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE THIS IS
THE ORIGINAL.
AFTER SCHOOL YOUTH PROGRAM THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHO HAS
CULTIVATED GENERATIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE GONE ON TO
MANY LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE
AND
ONCE AGAIN MEMBERS IF WE COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER.
MISTER HOLD AND WILL BE MAKING
AN INTRODUCTION FROM MY GAS.
MR HOLD AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE.
HERE THIS MORNING AND THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO STAND
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF
OF BRIDGET JONES SAWYER.
OUGHT TO RECOGNIZE --
MR ZERO FEENEY.
SO FREELY.
IS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
OF THE PASADENA TOURNAMENT OF
ROSES ASSOCIATION AT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY YEAR HISTORY.
MR PRETTY WILL PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP FOR THE HUNDRED
THIRTIETH ROSE PARADE AND THE
HUNDRED FIFTH ROSE BOWL GAME ON
TUESDAY.
JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN MEMBERS
JUST AND KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO
WEAR THIS RED JACKET.
AS OTHER PRESIDENTS HAVE IT'S
TAKEN OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
VOLUNTEER SERVICE TO THE TERM
AROSE ASSOCIATION.
AND SO WITH THAT KIND OF
DEDICATION AND STICK TO IT OF
THIS WE APPRECIATE MR BRAINIEST.
COMMITMENT. TO THE ORGANIZATION
BUT ALSO TO THE COMMUNITY.
THIS YEAR'S THEME THE MELODY OF
LIFE [inaudible]
HIGHLIGHTS MUSIC.
MUSIC'S ROLE AS A UNIVERSAL
LANGUAGE WOULD LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE.
THE PREVIOUS.
ROGER RODAS HERE WITH HIS WIFE
TRINA.
AND WE APPRECIATE THEM BEING
HERE THIS MORNING AND LIKE TO
BRING A GREAT WELCOME FOR THIS
FLOOR FROM THIS ASSEMBLY.
AND A RECOGNIZING DROVE RAINY.
AS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT OF THE TOURNAMENT OF
ROSES ASSOCIATION
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE AT SECOND READING
[inaudible]
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL 321-522-1660
869-172-1750 976-583-3920
696-510-8510 901-135-1160 TWO U..
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX TWELVE HUNDRED
TWELVE THIRTY SIX TWELVE THIRTY
NINE TWELVE FORTY NINE SMALL.
521-408-1412 1-424-145-9170
519-226-9530 262-976-2790. FIVE
EIGHT EIGHTEEN EIGHT NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE NO 490-991-2960.
797-297-7980 1-908-710-2210.
281-036-1030 NINE TEN FORTY TEN
FIFTY ONE AND 541-073-1070
810-801-11011 331-136-1130.
711-631-16511 NINETY FIVE ELEVEN
NINETY SIX SLOW ONES.
SEVENTEEN TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR
WELL 811-283-1290. 313-041-33813
551-358-3060 1-136-513-7413
834-035-1480 TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TO FOURTEEN NINETY EIGHT THAT'S
YOU KNOW THREE THIRTEEN OF
PORTANTINO FIVE FIFTY NO. NINE
FOURTEEN TEN WITH AMENDMENTS AND
HAD A SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU KATIE ALL BILLS HAVE
BEEN DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE SB ELEVEN SIXTY THREE
GALGIANI FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND MOVE THEM TO THE INACTIVE
FILE.
AS THE FIVE THIRTY TWO DODD AND
S. B. TEN FIFTY ONE DODD.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NOTE.
AND MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN POINT TWO
I AM RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
I DON'T WANNA THREE AB FOR FOUR
A DALY TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
I DON'T WANT OH FIVE AB SIXTEEN
NINETY EIGHT DALY TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
AND ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN AB THIRTY
TO FIFTY TWO BY THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE.
TO THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY SIX THAT'S AB.
NINETEEN OH EIGHT BY MISTER
CHAVEZ CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER CHAVEZ AND
ACT LIKE MORRELL DISTRICTS
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAVEZ.
THANK YOU SIR AB NINETEEN NO
WAIT IS BACK OF CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS MADE WITH THE SENATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES CHAVEZ SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT AYE
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB FOURTEEN OH
SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN A SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL FACILITIES.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB FORTINO SIX WHICH
CREATES PARROTING THE EDUCATION
CODE FOR AUTHORIZING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO JOINT
OCCUPANCY LEASE.
AND LEASE LEASEBACK AGREEMENT
FOR UP TO NINETY NINE YEARS OF
THIS IS BACK ON CONCURRENT SOME
RESPECT WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
NAMES GLORIA SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
ZYDECO [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY EIGHT AND
EIGHTY NINE AS WELL AS NINETY
PASS A RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NINETY ONE
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
MISTER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
NINE WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO
ENCOURAGE THE GOVERNING BOARD OF
EACH SCHOOL DOES.
CHARTER SCHOOL WHO OFFERS
LANGUAGE COURSES DESIGNED FOR
NATIVE SPEAKERS.
THEY'RE NOT APPROVE THAT EIGHT
TWO G. COURSES TO SUPPORT THEIR
RESPECTIVE SCHOOLS IN SUBMITTING
THOSE COURSES TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE.
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNING BOARD OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MUST MANY
FOREIGN LANGUAGE COURSE SUCH AS
A HERITAGE FORT LANGUAGE COURSES
TO THE YOU SEEN CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. FOR
CERTIFICATION AND ADDITION TO
THE SCHOOLS APRIL G. REQUIREMENT
LIST.
IF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT DOES NOT
SUMMIT DIRT COURSES THE STUDENT
CANNOT USE THESE COURSES TO
FULFILL THE FOREIGN LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENT FOR APPLICATIONS TO
THE UC AND CSU SYSTEM.
MANY STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
BILINGUAL BUT ARE OFTEN
RESTRICTED FROM ADDING A THIRD
LANGUAGE TO MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT.
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
NOT SUBMITTED A HERITAGE
LANGUAGE COURSE. FOR
CERTIFICATION INSTEAD VASTLY
IMPROVING THE WRITING
ENCUMBRANCE OF SKILLS THAT ARE
BEHIND LIBERAL.
HERITAGE LANGUAGE COURSES THE
STUDENTS ARE LEFT SPENDING TWO
YEARS LEARNING A THIRD LANGUAGE
THAT MAY NOT BE.
OF USE TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL OR
CAREER GOALS BY ENCOURAGING THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS
AMENITIES COURSES.
ARE OFFICE HOPES TO SEE MORE
STUDENTS HAVING FURTHER
FLEXIBILITY AND PANNING OUT
THERE HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
PATHWAYS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THEY WAS GARCIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROAD TIME OUT I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO IS AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN AND
ACTUALLY THE CIVIL ACTIONS.
DOCTOR CHEN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIX IS BACK
FROM SENATE ON CONCURRENT SAID
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
IN THE SENATE WOULD EXTEND THE
TIME THAT PROCESS SERVICE CAN
DROP OFF NOTICES.
AND OTHER PAPERS TO EIGHT PM.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THEM TO DROP
THEM UNTIL SIX PM THIS CHANGE N
THE TIME FRAME ONLY BEFORE LEGAL
NOTICES THAT PERTAIN TO A CASE
HAS ALREADY COMMENCED.
AGAIN THIS WILL ONLY PERTAIN TO
NOTICE HIM TO SOMEONE AFTER THE
CASE HAS STARTED THIS BILL HAS
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIGHT UP.
THANK YOU JACKIE CHAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ANTI.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE HAS BEEN
MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE FILE
ITEMS NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE
AND NINETY SIX PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
NINETY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER LEVINE
AND OTHERS AND I JOIN TO
INSURANCE.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN PIT YOUR
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN WAS
BORN FROM LAST YEAR'S FIRES WHEN
A LOT OF FAMILIES FOUND
THEMSELVES UNDER INSURED.
THIS BILL IS TO HELP MAKE SURE
THAT -- THAT
OUR CUSTOMERS AND POLICY HOLDERS
HAVE THE BEST INSURANCE POSSIBLE
AND TO FIGHT THAT ISSUE OF UNDER
INSURANCE ARE THE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT THOUGH.
THEY INITIALLY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
NINETY EIGHT IS AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FIVE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ACTUALLY COLLEGE
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK.
ON CONCURRENCE IT URGES
PUBLISHERS TO GIVE MORE
INFORMATION ON A WEBSITE ABOUT
HOW A NEW EDITION OF A TEXTBOOK.
DIFFERS FROM A PREVIOUS EDITION.
AND THEN A STAKE IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL NATURE IN A
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT
THANKS.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE IS AB.
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED KERKORIAN AT
SOME THE BILL TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
BY SOME A MEMBER FLORA AND
ACTUALLY THE PARKS.
MR FLOOR YOU MAY OPEN.
THAT YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED BACK ON
CONCURRENT IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS OR
TECHNICAL NATURE THIS BILL
SUPPORT BOTH CAL.
LAUGHE CHO AS WELL AS LOCAL
AFTER IT WITH NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU I DON'T
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MR FLORENCE A NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
CALVET AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
CENTER AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE IN ONE
HUNDRED PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE ON ONE THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM ONE OF TO AB THREE
OH SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OF SIX BY
SOME THE MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND EXPLAIN TO
ELECTIONS.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE OF SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE
PERSON DESIGNATED TURNOUT OF
VOTERS COMPLETED MAIL BALLOT
RETURN IT WITHIN A SHORT TIME
LINE TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REDUCE POTENTIAL CONFUSION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS EXTENDED THE
TIME I'M FROM TWO TO THREE DAYS
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION CARDS AND PROVIDED
CLARIFICATIONS TO NOT DISQUALIFY.
AYE AN OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE BALLOT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTES.
THEY COMMITMENTS ALSO FLETCHER
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY THREE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FOR IS AB [inaudible]
SIX SIX FOUR THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX FOUR BY
SOME MEMBERS STEINORTH AND
ACTUALLY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
SURE STEINORTH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX
SIX FOUR IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE AYE RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS STEINORTH SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
[inaudible]
SORRY.
WELL IN ONE OF SIX IS PASSED
RETAIN.
WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN JUMPING TO FILE
ITEM ONE NO AID A. B. TWENTY ONE
A LOT PERMIT.
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
BIGELOW AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE LIVESTOCK INSPECTION MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE
[inaudible]
MISTER BIGELOW.
JUST SIMPLY REQUEST.
AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISSION BIGELOW.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL UP THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE WAS ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SIXTY NINE KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE IS AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
AND ACTUALLY THE RENTED VEHICLES
[inaudible]
MISTER VOEPEL.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE THAT IS ON
CONCURRENCE.
THIS MAJOR REDUCES THE FIVE DAY
WAITING PERIOD TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS FOR A RENTAL CAR COMPANY
TO REPORT A STOLEN VEHICLE.
THE BILL ENJOYS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND IS SUPPORTED BY BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOW VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLOCK CLUB WHERE ALL.
MEMBERS.
LIZARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
ONE TEN I DON'T WANNA LEBANESE
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY THE
FISHING.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AYE AB TWENTY THREE
IT'S NINE WOULD CRACKDOWN ON
POACHING BY COMMERCIAL ENTITIES
IN.
PROTECTED AREAS THE THE MINUTES
TAKING THE SENATE OR MINOR
CLARIFYING A RESPECT LAST WHEN I
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS ABOUT.
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE IS AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN FOR COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE TENANCY.
MISTER CHU YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR PAST SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TO PROTECT TENANTS FROM BEING
EVICTED OR OTHERWISE PENALIZE
FOR CALLING FOR EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE FACT
THAT TODAY UNDER CURRENT LAW
VICTIMS ARE PLACED IN AN
IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION OF EITHER
AND DURING A LIFE THREATENING
SITUATION. TO KEEP ONE'S HOME OR
CALLING FOR HELP AND RISK
BECOMING HOMELESS.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL THE BILL CONTINUES TO
HAVE NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
PASSED THUS FAR WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ZERO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
AS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT.
AYE AYES.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN IS AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER OF RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
THIS RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY FOUR WHICH IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AS A RIM MINDER
THIS BILL WOULD ONE NO LONGER
LOCKED COUNTIES TO REQUIRE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
APPLYING FOR TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS JANETTA TO
NOTIFY THE ALLEGED PERPETRATOR
IN ADVANCE AND TO IT WILL PERMIT
THE COURT. TO ALLOW AN
ALTERNATIVE METHOD OF SERVICE IF
AT THE TIME OF THE T. RO.
HEARING THE COURT DETERMINES THE
PETITIONER HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH PERSONAL SERVICE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY FOUR HAS
BEEN A CONSENT CANDIDATE
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT WE MADE SOME MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE WHICH IS WHY IT'S BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE TODAY.
THIS BILL PREVIEW PREVIOUSLY
PASSED THIS HOUSE WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I ANTICIPATE THE SAME TO BE
TRUE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND I STRONGLY URGE IN
MY VOTE.
THEY'VE IS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LOCAL
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY THREE KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL GASSED
IN THE CHAMBER.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IT'S MY GREAT HONOR TO
REPRESENT.
A TO INTRODUCE OF MY
CONGRESSWOMAN ZOLOFT AND
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S NINETEEN
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
CONGRESSWOMAN LOFGREN WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO CONGRESS IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR AND IS THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL [inaudible]
DELEGATION.
SHE SERVES ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND IS CHAIR OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY SUBCOMMITTEE ON
IMMIGRATION CITIZENSHIP.
CHOOSE THE RIGHT THE MEMBER WELL.
HE'S THE RANKING MEMBER OF THE
MOMENT.
HOPEFULLY AT SOME POINT ONCE
AGAIN WILL BE CHAIR OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY SUBCOMMITTEE ON
IMMIGRATION CITIZENSHIP REFUGEES
BORDER SECURITY.
AND INTERNATIONAL LAW PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING A WARM WELCOME
TO MY CONGRESS NUMBER SO THAT
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO TAKE UP.
MR MEDINA IS ITEMS.
MEDINA IS ON THE FLOOR WE ARE ON
THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK FILE
ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED THIS IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY THREE BY MR MEDINA
CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER MEDINA
AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
MR MEDINA YOU MAY OPEN.
NAY YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I WERE
DIAGNOSED.
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN ONE OF SEVEN THIS
IS AB.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER MEDINA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION GOVERNANCE
DECLARING THAT WOULD SEE THEIR
OUT TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
IS ALSO BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AGO THANK YOU MR MEDINA
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE COW THAT I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS FOR ON THE
MEASURE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
AND BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER
MEMBERS FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN
IS PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE AN ONE
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY NINE FORTY ONE
BY MISTER BERMAN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER BERMAN
AND ACTION TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN THE LAST MONTH
GOVERNOR BROWN IS DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN NINE
COUNTIES YOU TO WILD FIRES WHICH
ARE DESTROYED HOMES THREATEN
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND CAUSED THE EVACUATION OF
RESIDENTS.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY ONE IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE HEALTH PLAN AND
HEALTH INSURER TO PROVIDE THEIR
PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED
BY STATE OF EMERGENCY.
CONTINUED ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY HEALTH CARE SERVICES
SENATE AMENDMENTS ENSURE CLARITY
IN IMPLEMENTATION --
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY ONE IS
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THERE'S BERMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LIBERAL I'M VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN PASS RETAIN THAT BRINGS
US FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTEEN AB THIRTY TO FORTY
SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO FORTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AND I JOIN THE
TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION ON THE
BUS BILL TODAY.
A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY SIX IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS MADE ADDITIONAL
CLEANUP AND SIMPLE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
FOUND THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEMI NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEMS ON RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
CONTINUED THIS IS FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY THREE ONE TWENTY FOUR AND
ONE TWENTY FIVE WE ARE AT THE
THIRD READING FILE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS [inaudible] ONE
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH ONE TWENTY
NINE HOUSE RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY AC ARE TO SIXTY TWO
BY MISTER BIGELOW CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY TWO BY SOME THE NUMBER
BIGELOW AND OTHERS ABILITY TO
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF CHINESE
AMERICANS TING ASSEMBLY NATIONAL
PARK IN THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
MISTER BIGELOW YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR TWO SIX TO WHICH SEEKS TO
HONOR THE POSITIVE IN HISTORICAL
IMPACTS.
CHINESE AMERICANS HAVE HAD ON
YOU SOME OF THE NATIONAL PARK IN
THE SIERRA NEVADA.
EVERY YEAR THE CHINESE
HISTORICAL SOCIETY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LEADS AN ANNUAL
PUBLIC PROJECTS. TO RECOGNIZE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF EARLY
CHINESE AMERICANS IN YOSEMITE
AND THE SIERRA NEVADAS.
DURING THE MID EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS
THOUSANDS OF CHINESE IMMIGRANTS
JOURNEY TO THE WEST COAST
SEEKING GOLD AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
DESPITE BEING MET WITH ANTI
IMMIGRANT SENTIMENT AND RACISM
THE CHINESE SHOW TREMENDOUS
STRENGTH AND DIGNITY BY WORKING
JOBS NOT DESIRED BY OTHERS.
THEY FACED MUCH DANGER.
DURING THIS CONSTRUCTION AND
PIVOTAL TIME.
AND BUILDING ROADS IN YOSEMITE
INCLUDING.
FACING SNOW AND FREEZING
TEMPERATURES.
THE WATER ROAD WHICH LEADS TO
THE VALLEY IS TWENTY THREE MILES
LONG.
AND ASSUMES FOUR THOUSAND FEET
ALONG THE MOUNTAIN.
IT WAS DEVELOPED IN THE WINTER
OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE FROM
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE CHINESE ROAD
BUILDERS COMPLETED FIFTY SIX
MILES OF THE GREAT SIERRA WAGNER.
I WROTE KNOWN TODAY AS TIE OF
THE PAST OR BETTER PILED THE
ROAD.
THIS WAS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS AS
THEY WORKED.
OF THOUSANDS OF FEET.
EVERY DAY AND ALSO WORKED AT TEN
THOUSAND FEET ABOVE THE SEA
LEVEL TO CREATE ACCESS TO
YOSEMITE.
USING BLASTING POWDER.
THERE WERE ALSO SEVERAL NOTABLE
CHINESE CHEFS THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED IN HELPING SHAPE YOU
SOMEBODY.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF TRIVIA
FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE IT'S KIND
OF IMPORTANT [inaudible] ONE
SHAFT.
NAME TYSON MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MADE AN EVERLASTING IMPRESSION
ON MANY INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE U. S. GEOLOGICAL
SURVEY CAN.
COMMITTEE.
HE ALSO WORKED AS HEAD CHEF FOR
THE MAKE THEIR MOUNTAIN PARTY.
WHO WENT ON TO DEVELOP?
WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE?
HE WAS RECOGNIZED FOR HIS
EFFORTS NOT ONLY AS A CHEF BUT
IN HIS WISDOM AND LEADERSHIP IN
GUIDING.
SOME WISE CHOICES.
TODAY HIS LEGACY LIVES ON IN YOU
SEVENTY NATIONAL PARK.
THROUGH SCENES P. WHICH WAS
NAMED AFTER HIM IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE CHINESE
PIONEERS AND THAT TREMENDOUS
ADVANTAGE.
HAVE HAD A TREMENDOUS ROLE IN
SHAPING CALIFORNIA.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE TO ALSO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS AND
REQUEST THEIR SUPPORT. FOR THIS
ACR I WOULD ALSO REQUEST THAT
THAT WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW DOCTOR
CHEN YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS ARE RIGHT TODAY'S A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF ACR TWO SIX
TWO ONLY THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
O'NEILL'S FOR BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD.
IS A PORTS HONOR CHINESE PINE
YEARS YOU SEVENTIES HERE FOR
SEVERAL REASONS CHINESE
IMMIGRANTS PROVIDE A LOT OF
DEDICATION TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ALL OVER UNITED STATES
ESPECIALLY HERE.
IN CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD TO HONOR
THOSE WHO PLAYED AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN CREATING PUBLIC ACCESS
TO YOU FROM THE NATIONAL PARK AS
WELL AS HELPING VISITORS IN TWO
WAYS THEIR EXPERIENCE THE PARK.
MEMBERS I HUMBLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN
[inaudible]
MISTER CHIU.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HEARD A CHAIR I
ALSO ON THE RISE TO THANK OUR OF
COLLEAGUES.
ON O'NEILL TO HONOR THE CHINESE
AMERICAN AND OR OR EARLY
IMMIGRANT.
AND DIE NEXT YEAR WILL BE A
HUNDRED FIFTY YOUR CELEBRATION
OF THE COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCRIPT A TRANSCONTINENTAL
REAL ROLE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO A SOME
CELEBRATION UNDERGOES A DOME
BROODING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH CHU SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASSN THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON THIS IS CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ADDING ON ACR.
TWO SIX TWO IT'S CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROW THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS.
ONE THIRTY ONE THROUGH ONE
THIRTY THREE PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM. ONE
THIRTY FOUR H. R. ONE SIXTEEN BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI CORKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE SIXTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER MURATSUCHI BELT OF
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO INVOICE INVITE
YOU.
AND SOME OF THE GAS THAT I HAVE
IN THE GALLERY.
AND ALL JAPANESE AMERICANS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
COMMEMORATING.
THE THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SIGNING OF THE CIVIL LIBERTIES
ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ON
AUGUST TENTH NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
SIGNED THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT A
LANDMARK CIVIL RIGHTS BILL.
THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS PROVIDED
NO OFFICIAL POLICY [inaudible]
AND REDRESS. FOR THE UNJUST
INCARCERATION.
OF OVER ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS OF JAPANESE
ANCESTRY.
DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO WE HAVE TALKED MANY TIMES ON
THIS FLOOR.
ABOUT THE TRAGIC HISTORY.
OF THE WORLD WAR TWO JAPANESE
AMERICAN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
BUT LESS WELL KNOWN OR THE MANY
STORIES THAT WERE PART OF THE
GRASS ROOTS.
DECADES LONG MOVEMENT AND THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT LED TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT.
A MOVEMENT THAT WAS INSPIRED.
BY THE AFTER AMERICAN LED CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
OF THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
WE ARE JOINED IN THE GALLERY.
BY SOME OF THE MANY WHO ARE PART
OF THAT GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT.
THE CORPS OF THIS LANDMARK CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGISLATION.
WAS THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL INJUSTICE.
OF INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS.
AND IN PARTICULAR THEY KNOWLEDGE
MEANT.
THAT THING CAR SERRATION OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
WAS MOTIVATED BY QUOTE
[inaudible]
RACIAL PREJUDICE WARTIME
HYSTERIA.
AND THE FAILURE OF POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP [inaudible]
ANOTHER BIG.
CORE OF THIS LANDMARK
LEGISLATION WAS THE APOLOGY
ITSELF [inaudible]
WERE.
PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
SPEAKER [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
THE CONGRESS.
QUOTE APOLOGIZES ON BEHALF.
OF THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES. FOR THE EVACUATION
RELOCATION AND TORMENT.
OF JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
AND PERMANENT RESIDENT ALIENS.
SO.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME AND THOSE
THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT NOT JUST
[inaudible] TO COMMEMORATE.
THIS LANDMARK EVENT IN OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS HISTORY.
THAT ALLOWED FOR THE HEALING OF
A COMMUNITY
THAT WAS BETRAYED BY ITS
GOVERNMENT.
BUT THAT ALSO SHOWS [inaudible]
THE GREATNESS OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND THE WILLINGNESS OF OUR
COUNTRY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FUNDAMENTAL INJUSTICE.
BUT TO BE BIG ENOUGH AND STRONG
ENOUGH [inaudible] TO SAY.
WE AS A NATION APOLOGIZE FOR
THIS FUNDAMENTAL JUSTICE MEMBERS
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME.
IN SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION TO
COMER MATTER COMMEMORATE THE
THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SIGNING OF THE CIVIL LIBERTIES
ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT I
ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
AND I ASK FOR THE FIRST ROLE TO
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT
MEMBERS --
ARISE [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
OF EACH ARE ONE SIXTEEN AND LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
BRING IT --
FOR AND COMMEMORATING THIS
ANNIVERSARY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE REFLECT
ON ONE OF OUR NATION'S IN OUR
STATES --
DARKEST MOMENTS IN HISTORY.
WITH MORE THAN A 1-001-000-0800
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE OF
JAPANESE ANCESTRY BEING INTERNED --
WHERE ALMOST EVERY FIVE THOUSAND
AMERICAN CITIZENS A WERE
INCLUDED OUT WE MUST?
NEVER FORGET A MAKE SURE THIS
HISTORY IS TOLD THAT WE LEARN
FROM THESE MOMENTS AND RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL OF OUR STRUGGLES FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
ARE LINKED TOGETHER THAT THIS BE
A REMINDER OF HOW WE MUST BE
CONSTANTLY VIGILANT.
ABOUT PROTECTING CIVIL RIGHTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ON HR.
ONE SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER IN
[inaudible]
SEEING NO [inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE REMAINING.
THIS MURATSUCHI YOU LIKE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THAT CORRECT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS.
WHOLE AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIS IS CO AUTHORS
AND ONE SIXTEEN S. COAUTHORS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CLERK.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MR MERCY CHEAP
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO
GIVE A WARM WELCOME. TO DOCTOR
KANJI SAHARA OF TORRANCE.
BORN IN LOS ANGELES INCARCERATED
AND THE CONCENTRATION CAMP AND
JEROME ARKANSAS WHEN HE WAS
EIGHT YEARS OLD.
ALSO NANCY ODA.
OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY HER
FAMILY WAS ORIGINALLY FROM
PALMDALE.
SHE HERSELF WAS BORN IN THE TO
LATE CONCENTRATION CAMP THEY'RE
BOTH ACTIVE MEMBERS NOT ONLY.
OF THE JAPANESE AMERICAN REDRESS
MOVEMENT THAT I JUST TALKED
ABOUT BUT WHO ARE CONTINUE TO BE
ACTIVE RIGHT NOW FIGHTING FOR A
PERMANENT MONUMENT --
AT THE TUNA CANYON DETENTION
SITE PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
DOCTOR SAHARA AND NANCY ODA
.
NUMBER BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FIVE HR ONE EIGHTEEN
BY DOCTOR QUIRK CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION BY SOME A
MEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO MUSLIM AMERICAN APPRECIATION
AWARENESS MONTH.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
HR ONE ONE EIGHT RECOGNIZES
AUGUST AS MUSLIM AMERICAN
APPRECIATION AND AWARENESS MONTH.
EACH YEAR ONE ARE T. H. R.. ONE
EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO EDUCATION.
SCIENCE ENTERTAINMENT AND
MEDICINE EXTEND EXTEND
NATIONALLY AND GLOBALLY.
THEY'RE PUBLIC SERVANTS TEACHERS
DOCTORS VETERANS.
SOCIAL WORKERS AND STUDENTS.
YES THE MUSLIM AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES
TO BE THE TARGET OF HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN THE SALTS.
IN FACT A REPORT RECENTLY ISSUED
BY ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SIERRA.
DOCUMENTED INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES AGAINST MUSLIM COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA.
ON A NATIONAL LEVEL THERE
THREATEN FACING THREATS OF
REGISTRIES AND TAB TRAVEL BANS.
THIS UPSETTING AND UNACCEPTABLE.
ARE AND IT IS WHY I HAVE
INTRODUCED HR.
ONE ONE EIGHT THIS IS A SIGNAL
OF CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
DETERMINATION.
STAND WITH OUR MUSLIM BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO WANT NOTHING
MORE THAN WHAT WE WANT. TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES.
I HAVE A GOOD LIFE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR.
ONE ONE EIGHT AS A PROUD
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR.
NEVER WAS THERE A MORE IMPORTANT
TIME THEN NOW TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE AND VALUE.
OF THE MUSLIM AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
OTHERS SOLDIERS AND SCIENTISTS
OR TEACHERS AND ENTREPRENEURS.
WAS AMERICANS CONTRIBUTED
CONTRIBUTED MIGHTILY.
ACCESS OF OUR STATE.
AND NATION.
I IN FACT EVEN AS PUBLIC
SERVANTS LAST MONTH.
WILL GOVERNOR BROWN APPOINTED
JUSTICE HOLLIMAN MANY DONNA THE
FIRST MOST AMERICAN JUSTICE IN
THE HISTORY.
THE CALIFORNIA COURTS OF APPEAL
AND THIS WEEK IN MICHIGAN WITH
THE ELECTION OF RASHEEDA FLY YOU
UP.
THE FIRST MUSLIM AMERICAN WOMAN
IN THE HISTORY.
OF THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
ONCE SWORN AND WE ARE SEEING
MORE AND MORE REPRESENTATION OF
OUR MOST AMERICAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN ELECTED AND JUDICIAL
SERVICE.
LET US USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THE RICH HISTORY AND
SHARE PRINCIPLES OF MOST
AMERICANS.
AND RISE ABOVE INSTANCES OF HATE
AND INTOLERANCE TO A PLACE
RESPECT.
ARE MOVING TO MAINTAIN A PLACE
RESPECT AND ADMIRATION FOR OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
I LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM HAYWARD FOR
BRINGING FORTH THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT HR.
ONE EIGHTEEN THEY WAS KALRA
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO ALSO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES AND
SUPPORTING.
THIS RESOLUTION TO RECOGNIZE THE
MUSCLE AMERICAN APPRECIATION AND
AWARENESS MONTH.
AND I WOULD LIKE.
TO A TIE MY EARLIER COMMENTS
WITH THIS IMPORTANT TO A
RESOLUTION AND THAT --
YOU KNOW JUST AS JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE TREATED AS
NATIONAL SECURITY THREATS DURING
WORLD WAR.
TWO TODAY WE'RE SEEING A
MEASURES LIKE THE MUSCLE TRAVEL
BAN AND OTHER MEASURES TARGETING
MUSLIM AMERICANS AS NATIONAL
SECURITY THREATS AND SO IN
CONTINUATION OF MY EARLIER
COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF LEARNING
THE LESSONS OF THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN INTERNMENT.
I ASK THAT WE KEEP IN MIND THAT
WE NOT REPEAT [inaudible]
HISTORY.
WE NOT REPEAT WHAT HAPPENED A
JAPANESE AMERICANS AS WE SEE
MUST SOME AMERICANS BEING
TREATED TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION I'M
SORRY.
KANSEN CHU MISTER CHIU YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
UNSECURE MISTER SPEAKER I'M AYE
RIGHTS HAS.
TO PRINCE VOCAL AUTHOR OF EACH
ARE ONE EIGHTEEN AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE WORK.
OF FOR INTRODUCING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
THIS MONTH WE CELEBRATE THE D.
MOST ONCE AMERICAN IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THEIR CONTRIBUTION.
AS TO CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRYING.
I ENCOURAGE COMMUNITY TO REACH
OUT TO OUR A MUSLIM NEIGHBORS TO
BUILDING UP BRIDGES AND
UNDERSTANDING AND STRONG
COMMUNICATION OR TO BUILD A
STRONGER COMMUNITY.
DURING OF OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
A LONG TO YOU AS THE HATE CRIMES
THE STATE ALL THAT ON HATE CRIME
WAS TO JAIL AT COMMITTEE --
JUST LOTS OF A TWO STORY WE
HEARD OF ALL THE HATE AGAINST
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THEIR
RELIGION IN THEIR CLASSROOM.
MOSTLY COMMUNITY YOU MEMBERS
IT'S A REAL REALITY OF BLOOD
ENTIRE GENERATION OF MUSLIMS AND
AMERICAN.
CHILDREN THAT HAVE GROWN UP IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE HATE THINGS
NIGHT.
ELEVEN WE NEED TO DO BETTER
PREVENT US HATE.
AND MAKE ALL OF OUR KIDS FEEL
SAFE AND WELL COME IN THEIR
CLASSROOM.
LET'S NOT LIMITED OURSELF TO
BREEN AWARENESS AND APPRECIATION
IT JUST IN THE MONTHS OF AUGUST.
THAT'S STOOD AT OF ALL THE TIME
AND LOOKS TO DIE FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
SCENE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION DOCTOR QUIRK
BACK FOR YOU BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA'S TO STATE THAT THE
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF ITS
DIVERSE POPULATION.
IT IS IMPORTANT BIG KNOWLEDGE IN
HONOR THE MANY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THAT.
MAKE UP CALIFORNIA AND OUR
NATION.
AND MAKE IT A BETTER PLACE TO
LIVE AND WORK.
I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
I INVITE YOU TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES FROM TORRANCE --
SAN JOSE AND MY SENATOR FROM
FREMONT --
IN STANDING WITH OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND VOTE
ARE I ONE HR ONE ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU.
THANK THAT QUIRK FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR COOPER IS MEMBERS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
CO AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RATHER SIXTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ME TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND DOCTOR QUIRK YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
YES SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF A
VERY SPECIAL GUEST WITH ME TODAY.
AZIZ OCT BARRING.
ZZ GREW UP IN FREMONT AND
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE STUDIED INDUSTRIAL IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING SECTION SYSTEMS
ENGINEERING.
WITH A CONCENTRATION IN RESOURCE
PLANNING AND DATA SCIENCE.
SEIZE RETURNED TO HIS HOMETOWN
AFTER GRADUATION AND HAS BEEN A
ROLE MODEL FOR OUR YOUTH.
Z. H. WAS TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER DISTRICT'S.
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN HIS YOUNGEST
CANDIDATE TO EVER BE ELECTED IN
THE WATER DISTRICTS A HUNDRED
AND TWO YEAR OLD HISTORY.
AND THE YOUNGEST MUSLIM AMERICAN
TO BE ELECTED TO ANY PUBLIC
OFFICE IN THE COUNTRY.
HE HAS A PASSION FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE AND IS COMMITTED. TO
BREAKING PROCEED SOCIETAL.
BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN.
ABOUT THAT HAVE.
BROWN TODAY'S YOUTH.
IT ALSO SAYS A LOT ABOUT
CALIFORNIAN MY DISTRICT.
SOMEONE WITH THE NAME IZZY'S OCT
BARRING COULD BE ELECTED TO AN
OFFICE IN THE DISTRICT WITH
CLOSE TO FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
PLEASE GET THIS INSPIRING YOUNG
MAN VERY WARM ASSEMBLY WELCOME
HE IS AT THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER
AND HE HAS FRIENDS AND RELATIVES.
UP IN THE WHO I'D LIKE TO HAVE
STAND UP IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
AND THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT
THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M GIVING A ONE
DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM A
TWELVE SP FOUR SEVENTY THREE
HERTZBERG FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
CLERK WILL KNOW. ONE DAY NOTICE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO SET A
THIRD RAINY.
SENATE THERE READING FILE.
IS FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY SIX S. B. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AND ACTUALLY
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY EIGHT IS
A SAFETY FOCUSED MEASURE THAT
WILL ENSURE PROSPECTIVE
HOMEOWNERS ARE INFORMED.
MORE SPECIFICALLY.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE HOME
INSPECTORS TO HAVE A WRITTEN
NOTIFICATION IN THEIR FINAL
REPORT OF YELLOW CORRUGATED
STAINLESS STEEL TUBING.
ALSO KNOWN AS YELLOW CCSD.
WHICH IS SEEN DURING A REGULAR
INSPECTION.
YELLOW CCSD IS FLEXIBLE METAL
GAS TUBING WHICH HAS BEEN
INSTALLED IN OVER SIX MILLION
HOMES IN THE UNITED STATES SINCE
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES.
OVER HALF OF THE YELLOW SEA CST
INSTALLATIONS IN THE U. S. WORK
COMPLETED PRIOR TO THE DIRECT
BONDING SAFETY UPDATE TO THE
MANUFACTURER'S INSTRUCTIONS AND
NATIONAL.
FUEL GAS CODES.
RESEARCH CONFIRMS PROPER BONDING
AND GROUNDING SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE RISK OF DAMAGE AND
FIRE FROM INDIRECT LIGHTNING
STRIKE.
AND IT IS UNCLEAR HOW MANY HOMES
IN CALIFORNIA.
WERE INSTALLED WITH YELLOW CCSD
PRIOR TO THE NATIONAL CODE
UPDATE. FOR THIS REASON IT IS
CRITICAL THAT PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE INFORMED THAT YELLOW CCS T.
IS NOTICED DURING A STANDARD
HOME INSPECTION.
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE IT
INVESTIGATED BY A LICENSED
ELECTRICIAN.
SENATE BILL NINETY EIGHTY EIGHT
IS PART OF A NATIONWIDE SAFETY
CAMPAIGN TO BRING AWARENESS TO
HOMEOWNERS ON THE IMPORTANCE A
PROPER BONDING OF YELLOW CCSD.
AND THE POTENTIAL RISKS IF IT IS
NOT PROPERLY BONDED. TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY HOME
INSPECTORS SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT WAS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
IMPACT CURRENT STANDARDS OF
LIABILITY FOR HOME INSPECTORS.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION AND WILL IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAGO
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
ONE KNOWS FIVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP THE AMENDMENTS ON
SENATOR REALLY FILE CLEAR GOING.
TO TAKE OF THE AMENDMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO JUMP TO FOLLOW
HIM.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN S. B. NINE TEN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL NINE TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
WOULD.
DOCTOR WOULD ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD DELETE THE
TERMS INCLUDING RENEWALS FROM
THE DEFINITION OF SHORT TERM
LIMITED DURATION HEALTH
INSURANCE AND MAKE OTHER NON
SUBSTANTIVE TECHNICAL CHANGES.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT
PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING QUICKLY TO
TAKE UP AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FIVE S. B. SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH MINUTES
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A
MEDICALLY.
MISTER COOLEY ON THE AMENDMENTS.
COLLEAGUES --
I'M HERE TO PRESENT REMISS SP.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT SPILLED DEALS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING.
BILL REQUIRES EACH COUNTY
COMPLETES AND NO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
ACT REVENUE AND EXPENSE
REPORTING COMPLIANCE WITH GAP
GENERALLY ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING
PRINCIPLES.
THE MEMBERS WILL CLARIFY THAT
THAT REPORT NEEDS TO BE TEXT
SEARCHABLE RATHER MACHINE
READABLE.
OUR CHRISTMAS BICU DOT TO PUT
UP PRINT BACK ON THANK YOU MISS
COOLEY SEE NO DISCUSSION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE SAME NAME.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT PRINTED
BACK ON FILE.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SIX S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORPOREAL WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
NUMBER RODRIGUEZ MISS RODRIGUEZ
ON THE AMENDMENTS MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TO THEIR PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND WERE REQUESTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL TO
EIGHT AND IMPLEMENTATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZAND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE.
A VOICE VOTE ON THE MEMONS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
WHERE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN
SP TEN FIFTY FIVE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY
WITH AMENDMENTS?
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER OF
THE MOUND.
MISLIM ON ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS S.
B. TEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD
AUTHORIZE BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS IN CALIFORNIA TO OFFER
PRICE LINKED SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING THE
NATURE AND INCORPORATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THING IS LIMON SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH IT'S HAVE AT THE MEMBERS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS HOW TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
BE MOVING TO CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS ANY MEMBER WAS REMOVED ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING NONE THE CLERK.
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CAL.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR BELL AND ACTUALLY THE
WATER CORPORATIONS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
IS HE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE THOUGH.
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CORKERY THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SIMPLE
TWELVE FORTY FOUR I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY FIVE I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
AUGUST TENTH NO FLOOR SESSION A
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY.
AUGUST THIRTEENTH FLOOR SESSION
IS A ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS RAN PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS.
IN MEMORY
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPETS
PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES WILL
BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY A FEW
PITS FROM PASS ROBLES.
YOU LIVE WORK AND SOLD REAL
ESTATE IN THE PAST ROBLES AREA
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN HE
WAS A TEXAS NATIVE.
TRANSPLANTED TO CALIFORNIA HE
PLAYED FOOTBALL AT TCU.
AND WAS A DEVOUT FAN OF THE
HORNED FROGS COULD OFTEN BE SEEN
WEARING A PURPLE.
SURE IN HONOR OF HIS ALMA MATER.
I HE WAS A WONDERFUL MAN HE WAS
A PILLAR OF OUR PILLAR OF OUR
COMMUNITY --
HE SURVIVED BY LESLIE'S WIFE
NEWS TWO DAUGHTERS THE PASSED
AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY OF A HEART
ATTACK.
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AFTER FISHING
TRIP WITH HIS FRIENDS BUT HIS
LAST DAYS WERE SPENT.
ENJOYING HIS TIME WITH HIS
FRIENDS.
I HE WAS HONORED AS THE ROEBLING
OF THE YEAR FOR PASS ROBLES AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN HE WAS GENEROUS
HE WAS KIND.
IF YOU HAD HUGH.
IN YOUR CORNER.
IN PART DUE TO HIS IMMENSE SIZE
BUT ALSO HIS IMMENSE SPIRIT AND
GENEROSITY YOU WERE LUCKY INDEED
ACCOUNT HIM.
AS A FRIEND --
AND HE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM.
MISTER LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF
MITCH SPEED.
MITCHELL BATTLEON FORSMAN
OFFICER FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
THEN IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MITCH WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE FOR PROSTATE CANCER.
ON THAT DAY.
STEPPED AWAY FROM WORKING
COMMITTED IS LIFE ENTIRELY TO
GOD.
MITCH HAD ONE REQUEST.
HE ASKED GOD USM.
IN HIS JOURNEY TO HELP OTHERS
WHATEVER WAY GOD DECIDED.
PRIOR TO IS DIAGNOSIS MATCH
WORKED AS A DETECTIVE FOR ONE OF
THE LARGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE NATION.
HIS DUTY ASSIGNMENT WAS TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS INTO
VIOLENT CRIMINAL CASES.
PRIOR TO WORKING AS A DETECTIVE
MATCH PUSHED RADIO CAR.
I WORKED THE STREETS WERE
HANDLED ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE.
WHAT IT CALLS A SIDE TO HIM?
A SOFT STORY SAW SOMEONE IN
DISTRESS SHE ACTED ON INSTINCT.
HE DREW FROM HIS VAST AMOUNT OF
TRAINING BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HE
DREW FROM PAST EXPERIENCES TO
GUIDE THEM.
HE SAW THE WORLD THROUGH A
DIFFERENT SET OF EYES AS HIS
EYES HAVE SEEN THINGS THAT WERE
UNEXPLAINABLE ON PAPER.
AFTER IS DIAGNOSIS MITCH'S LIFE
TOOK ON A MUCH DEEPER MORE
POWERFUL PURPOSE AS GOD OPENED
HIS EYES NEARS SO MANY THINGS.
HE HAD BEEN MISSING THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS.
I KNOW THESE THINGS TO BE TRUE
IS MISS.
MITCH WISHES TO SHARE WITH YOU
FROM HIS FROM THE PAGES OF HIS
BOOK.
I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME ON A
JOURNEY IN MID SPEECH MEMORY.
A PASSING ALONG CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY.
AND MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS UP.
ON JULY TWENTY NINTH CAPTAIN
BRIAN HUGHES OF THE ARROWHEAD.
HOT SHOTS BASED IN SEQUOIA AND
KINGS CANYON NATIONAL PARKS.
LOST HIS LIFE IN THE LINE OF
DUTY WHILE FIGHTING THE FERGUSON
FIRE.
HE WAS THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD.
CAPTAIN BRIAN USE WAS BORN IN
HAWAII IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR MADE HIS
WAY TO THE CONTINENTAL UNITED
STATES IN THE COLORADO UP IN OF
ALASKA AS WELL AND THEN I CAME
TO A CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
OF WHEN HE WAS ASSIGNED A VERY
YOUNG CAPTAINCY --
TO THE HOT SHOTS IT IS YOUTH HE
HAD A BRIEF UP.
FLIRTATION TO BECOME A STUNT MAN --
BUT TO HIS CAREER PATHWAY.
APART FROM THAT BRIEF LITTLE A
MOMENT.
A WAS TO BECOME A FIREFIGHTER HE
WANTED TO DO IT FROM FROM.
AT THE VERY FIRST TIME HE UP THE
THOUGHT SERIOUSLY ABOUT WHAT HE
WANTED TO DO ANY.
HE GAVE EVERYTHING TO IT AS SO
MANY OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS DO --
HE WAS IS A NAME THE LATAM AT TO
THE OF LARAMIE COUNTY YELLOW
JACKETS IN FORT COLLINS COLORADO.
TWO YEARS LATER HE WENT TO A
LAST.
SONS A HOT SHOT.
CREW AT THE NEXT YEAR HE JOINED
THE ROOSEVELT HOT SHOTS IN THEM
AS SIX YEARS --
HE WAS THERE IS THE EL ON THE
AIR ARROWHEAD CREW AND THEN IN
MARCH TWENTY FIFTEEN KIND OF A
DREAM.
COME TRUE FOR BRIAN HE MOVED TO
SQUAW VALLEY CALIFORNIA HE
ASSUMED THE CAPTAINCY OF THE
ARROWHEAD INTER AGENCY.
HOT SHOTS.
YEAH BRIAN AS A CAPTAIN --
WAS KNOWN AS A TRUSTED LEADER HE
WAS A MENTOR TO THE OTHER CREW
MEMBERS HE LED BY EXAMPLE HE
INSPIRED OTHERS.
AND HE INTUITIVELY GRASP AT THE
BIG PICTURE STRATEGIES THAT
ENABLED HIM TO EFFECTIVELY BREAK
DOWN THE STRATEGIES INTO
ACTIONABLE STEPS.
HIS CREW LOVED HIM AND LOOKED UP
TO HIM.
NOW.
AS A BROTHER.
BRIAN PUT OTHER PEOPLE FIRST
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE.
S. STOPPING TO HELP PEOPLE NO
MATTER WHAT.
MAN OF STRONG MORALS --
HE HAD A CLEAR SENSE OF WHAT WAS
RIGHT AND WRONG AND ALWAYS TRIED
TO DO.
WHAT WAS RIGHT HE LOVED THE
CAMARADERIE OF THE TEAM?
DROVE HIMSELF TO CONTRIBUTE AS
MUCH AS HE COULD TO THE GROUP.
THIS WAS A SHARP SAVVY YOUNG MAN
HE WAS MOVED TO HELP TO LEARN
NEW THINGS AND TO DO THAT.
KIND OF JOB AS A CAPTAIN THAT
WOULD MAKE A HIS.
CREW MEMBERS PROUD OF HIM. TO
HIS FAMILY GRAB BRIAN WAS THIS
CAREFREE RELAXED.
FUNNY YOUNG MAN TO GET A DRY
SENSE OF HUMOR AND HE WOULD
OFTEN.
BREAK HIMSELF UP.
AND CHUCKLE. TO HIS OWN HERE --
HE WAS A FRIEND TO EVERYONE WHO
MET THEM HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
JOINING FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
AND FOLKS FROM THE FIRE SERVICES
AT HIS FUNERAL.
IN FRESNO AND ALTHOUGH IT WAS
BETTER BECAUSE OF THE LOS.
IT WAS SWEET BECAUSE OF THE MAN
AND THE LEGACY HE LEFT BEHIND.
THIS SADLY --
BRIAN THIS IS LEFT BEHIND
[inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
PAGE HIS.
A FIANCE WHO ARE [inaudible]
DON'T HAVE [inaudible]
BROWN'S BABY.
HE WILL NEVER.
SHE THE BABY BUT THERE WILL BE.
ANOTHER HUGH IS A COMING ALONG.
AND SO FOR A LOT OF REASONS THAT
PEOPLE IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THE FIREFIGHTERS.
ACROSS THE STATE --
JOIN TOGETHER IN CELEBRATING HIS
LIFE.
REMINDING --
EACH OTHER OF THEIR DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRY TO LIVE
UP TO THE LEGACY.
OF BRIAN HUGHES AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT THIS BODY WILL
ADJOURN AND MEMORY OF THIS YOUNG
MAN [inaudible]
AND ALSO [inaudible] TO COMMIT.
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND PRAY FOR ALL OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS AS THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS CATASTROPHE
MAY GOD PROTECT THEM ALL.
THANK YOU IT'S PATTERSON.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME OF
THE DESK TO REPRINT IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEN HEARD ENOUGH FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER LACKEY MOVES AND MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST THIRTEENTH.
AND ONE PM WE ARE ADJOURNED